she doesn't want a baby she doesn't want
a baby
baby can you hear us
no you're safe what the hell
please get out of my house moment we've
been waiting for people
it's here asuelu straight up tackled his
sister tammy
and kicked her and his mom out of
kalani's parents house
but for once i will say that aswell's
mom was right
when it comes to this particular
altercation he started it
i'll tell you how in just a few so how
much your house cost
also that wasn't the only jaw-dropping
moment from tamtam and fam
i need money from you when i go back to
someone
yep these two are still requesting that
kalani and asuelu
pay up of course she brings up money and
there's not enough words to describe
how irritated i actually am we're going
to talk about it
plus yara slapped jovi at the strip club
and although i don't condone slapping
your husband
he deserved it why'd you slap me like i
thought we were having fun in there
we'll get into his extremely
disappointing behavior
that had me yelling at the screen leave
him girl
leave him you have to ruin every night
don't make me just love you again okay
because now i will do it my heart
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
this episode was so good let's hop right
into kalani in our swalu's family fight
it just feels like satan is on my
doorstep
well that's ironic because it's
christmas
[Music]
starting from the top aswell's mom
specifically his sister tammy
came through the door just zapping away
all the holiday cheer
tammy say hi to kennedy but she didn't
say
hello to kalani she walked past without
saying anything
how are you gonna walk into somebody's
house and not speak to them
walking in and seeing tammy and her mom
uh was a little uncomfortable
obviously there's a part of me that
wants to
do exactly what she said and come in
swinging but i'm not just going to jump
on her when she walks through the door
i know most of us secretly wanted her to
to be able to restrain yourself
and be pleasant to someone after they
spoke to you like this
over zoom i will beat you up too
oh yeah i would beat up galani and beat
you up
takes strength so kudos to kalini
so how much your house cost the
disrespect
i don't know i didn't buy this house
must be expensive but
because it's big and has a big backyard
tammy started easing her way into the
money conversation early on
by talking about how nice the house is
and speculating the cost
i feel like i can trust my brother
because how can he bait that house that
big
big house how if he's not able to help
our family back home so
he has money i know he has money but he
just
don't want to help our family at all but
girl
didn't your brother just tell you he
didn't buy the house so how much your
house cost um i don't know i didn't buy
this house
he's there because he can't afford a
place of his own
i hate to do this but duh
it's so wild how tammy wants to hold on
to the idea that he's lying
so bad that she can't see the obvious
what kind of work do you do in samoa and
weave the mess
dinner was cute at first a lot of small
talk until the sun sit down six o'clock
and go and relax the bingo
that's what makes me happy and then
bingo
oswell's mom flat out asked for some
money
i still want to say something to my son
and kalani i'm older now so
i need money from you when i go back to
somewhere
you give the money to me and god bless
you you think about that
now i respect the fact that giving money
to parents is a cultural tradition in
samoa
but do not try to use god to guilt-trip
them
so god will only bless them if they give
you money
right that's a good question okay
well oswello told his mom that if he
gives her money
it will only be a little if you need
money for food we
can spend little amounts of money we're
not going to send
she said a little kalani went on to
explain that they don't want to give her
money and she ends up giving it away to
other people
which is something asuelu said that she
would do often when he was younger
our mom always give money to the church
and think and we're not
eating a nice food and those people
eating good food we only eat taro or
rice
at this point of course tammy has to
jump in with her two cents
when you send the money means it goes
straight to your parents
you don't question them but ultimately
asuelu said
no because he doesn't have everything
that he wants yet
so you want me to send money now so you
guys will feel paid up
and my case will be stopping
no of course she brings up money and
there's not enough words to describe
how irritated i actually am let's change
the
mind from money and all those
unnecessary
things this is christmas holidays we
should have fun
so we're gonna play some white elephant
game what it's a gift exchange yeah it's
a funny gift exchange
i bought all the presents for it and was
planning to wait after the dinner now
i'm not gonna lie when i swallow said he
bought gifts
i thought to myself they better not be
nice gifts
that's gonna give his mom and tammy more
reason to request money the gifts that
oswego picked for the white elephant
exchange were freaking hilarious
thankfully the gifts proved that asuela
was being honest about his financial
situation
they included fart spray for his mom
spray no sauce
it's not a nose spray toilet paper for
kalani as a nod to 2020
a can of spam for kalani's dad i want
the spam
in a fake lottery ticket for tammy
but then he pulls out another gift
just for kalani but i have one thing i
want to
give it to my wife which was probably
the silliest of them all
oh what's that
it's a baby blanket baby
i want to have a big family so hopefully
my wife
will make my dreams come true i don't
want to keep being pressured into having
a baby
i swallow and you thought it was okay
to do this grand gesture in front of
these people
help me to make it make sense please
somebody did he think they could talk
kalani into doing it
did he think she would even listen to
them
i'm just confused why did he think this
was a good idea
i can't even believe that we're having
this conversation right now like i feel
like i'm in the twilight zone well
you're not happy about it
no i'm not ready to have another baby i
used to think about my brother like he
thinks
he has he wants to have a big family it
pisses me off
and the most hypocritical thing of all
is that tammy only has two kids
so why are we not bugging little tam tam
about putting some kids in her uterus
instead of talking to me about it clowny
look at me i'm
selfless i got nine children and i'm
fine no disrespect ma'am but
i don't think kalani is trying to be
like you
[Music]
it's her body she can say that she
doesn't want another baby in her body
right now her sister kallini ended up
stepping in
trying to take up for her but it's her
body
and it's their conversation well she's
talking we are nothing sure i took
kalani i know we're talking to kalani
about a baby and i don't know why
i'm talking for the same reason why
you're talking i'm talking
when they arrived kalani said it felt
like satan was on her doorstep
it just feels like satan is on my
doorstep
and well here's the moment when hell
broke loose
aswell's mom told him that he better
find another wife
and tammy suggested that he finds one in
samoa that's ridiculous
i told you guys to be on good behavior i
am
but that's why you gave her i doubt you
to be on good behavior
kalani is looking like what is happening
but boy oh boy she did not know what was
in store
cue the fight you shut up we're trying
to help you
and i'm gonna get into this house and
start yelling at him in his own house
we're talking to him he's my brother
she's my family now and he just said if
she doesn't want a baby she doesn't want
a baby
[Music]
come on let's go let's go wild right
i told y'all oswalo started it and lo
came in
just like a dad would late
what the hell get out well next week
oswello asked kalani something that
i even knew was an obvious no and he's
her husband
maybe we can move to samuel this has
been a really difficult year for us
and every time we make progress
something happens that just makes me
realize that we are completely different
people
well speaking of that i think yara and
jovi are starting to feel the exact same
way about each other
i was always serious and so what i got
just some fun
fake version for two years before you
came to america i always was a grandma
inside okay
it's the real me didn't accept it these
two have been on vacation in miami for a
couple of days now
i miss the old yard like you're not fun
anymore just to refresh your memory
jovi surprised her with the trip because
he said she's not fun
since she became a mom and he wanted
them to get back to having a
good time together so his mother gwen
tagged along to watch baby myla
which allowed yara and jovi to share
some quality time
i feel like since i've been home from
work you're using myla as an excuse
not to spend quality time with me not to
work in our relationship
and using her as a barrier to how you
really feel do not see that i'm using my
baby as a something because i was
talking about
oh the irony as you can see
things started off pretty rough on their
first night out yara was still in mommy
mode which frustrated jovi
and his reaction frustrated yara if we
still have problems when we go home then
we know this is not going to work the
next day they made up
and jovi promised yara a special night
out catered to her liking
we can go to a russian restaurant anu
romantic dinner
romantic dinner in russian restaurants
doesn't sell
why not because russia is not romantic
that's okay let's try fast forward to
dinner yara was in a great mood
and so was jovi maybe funyara will come
out tonight i feel like
you're in a good mood for that maybe i
will make for you strip this at home
oh yeah whatever yara came out tonight i
like it so far super dancing like this
yeah you can dance however you want how
about we go to strip club tonight
what's up buddy you're just so funny
maybe it'll make you feel a little bit
more alive like you're not just a boring
mom anymore
you i'm a boy mama yara wanted to prove
joby wrong
and make him happy so she agreed to go
no touching woman just no touching okay
i promise
now mind you this was her first time
going to a strip club
and jovi said over and over again if you
don't like it we go somewhere else no
big deal that they can leave whenever
she wants
okay if that's not fun you will bring me
to somewhere else yeah
of course okay but soon after they got
to the club
oh my goodness i don't know if it was
the liquor
or the stripper or a combination of both
but jovi forgot
all about his promises
[Music]
and although yara was uncomfortable she
did her part
she went and tried to have fun she even
made it rain on the stripper
[Music]
but it just got to a point where she was
over it especially after jovi touched
the stripper
and they agreed on no touching hey
i almost jumped through the screen how
dare you do her like that
i'm not married yet but i'd be damned if
my husband and i are having date night
and he chooses to stay in a strip club
over what would make me happy
it's our date night that's just
unacceptable
he's flat-out telling you what he cares
about no wonder yard just likes hanging
out with a baby
and i deserve better than this and oh
yeah
while his wife was sitting there feeling
awkward and ready to go
he blew a kiss at the stripper
what's your problem what's going on with
you why'd you slap me like i thought we
were having fun in there
you were having fun jovi i tell you
nicely from before i tell you
joey please can we go please jeffy
please please can we go so many women
will
uh be okay without you blowing the
kisses to the to the girl who is
destined in front of you
then all of a sudden you know stripper
took a top off after that y'all started
to get like okay i'm ready to get out of
here
i don't want to be here anymore i said i
would come for a little while and i was
like
i'm just thinking like what changed like
what's the big deal how did he not
see how that can be uncomfortable for
her i'm just curious
one it was her first time in an
environment like that
and she's with her husband and two
the strip club is not fun for everybody
that's just a fact
you have to ruin every night all this
problem isn't something i never do
you have to ruin every night don't make
me just love you again okay because now
i will do it with my heart
oh i just wanted to hug yara
as you can see i really feel bad for her
i don't know how jovi is going to come
back from this
i'm sure he will but it was just beyond
messed up
next week we're going to see the
aftermath from this night where's jovi
he didn't know he doesn't sleep here
what
i mean what happened he bring me the
strip club and then we fight and then he
goes away
in the beginning i had many doubts about
yara's intentions
now i'm starting to worry that jovi's
the one that wasn't ready
all right 90 day fans fam i need to go
relax after this episode
it was a lot but thanks for hanging out
with me
so make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news coming out the 90 day
universe make sure you stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time